FORMER WIZARD. GREAT PASS TO
LEBRON. IN THE
LEAGUE IN TRIPLE DOUBLES
LEBRON SCORES. AND
THAT'S WHAT FREED ND AND COMES
BOY, THAT'S TAPPED A
MAKES A DIFFERENCE IN RUSS AND
EASIER FOR FOR LEBRON.
YEAH. PROBABLY THE BEST TEAM
WIN OF THE YEAR. FANS STILL IN
RL MALONE AND  A
MOMENT FOR LEBRON JAMES.
CHANCE TO SALUTE LEBRON AS HE
SCORES AGAIN WHEN THEY COME
HOME. ON AFTER
ISH.
SCORE AND THE BRONZE
UNDEDEITH THAT.
>> Mark: BROOKLYN ABSOLUTELY
RIDICULOUS.
7 FOOT ON THE LINE.
NEW YORK IS IN BETTER
R.J. BARRETT MAKES THE SECOND. .
>> Doris: JUST DOES
>> Doris: THIS HAS MADE TWO
DRIVES AGAINST HIM.
THE FIRST TO QUICKLEY ON THE
DRIVE, AND EMBARRASSED AND
HIS PIED WASAS
GOT TO BE IMPRESSED WITH THIS
DURANT AND,
BUT
MILLS PULLS TO PHILADELPHIA
IN AURKS
CREDIT, RIGHT?
HE WAS THE ONE WHO DOUBLED AND
-- THAS
AGAINST A DOUBLE.
HE SEEKS THE CONTACT AND DRAWS .
CHANGE SIDE OF THE FLOOR, OPEN .
DRAGIC SHAKING
QUARTERBACK TELEGRAPHING HIS UP.
>> Doris: PRESSURE DOESN'T SEEM
TO AFFECT THIS GUY.
>> Mark: NO.
JAKOB POELTL, THE ROLLER,5% SINO
THE F
SAN ANTONIO.
AND THE WOLVES CATCH JUMPERS, AE
FLOOR.
>> Dave: EDWARDS,
>> Jim:
DEFENSE HAS NOT BEEN THE STRONG
SU
TOWNS
FLOOR. TIMBERWOLVES GET A STOP.
12 MINUTES.
TOWNS MOV
PLAYER OVER.
LONNIE WALKER HAS BEEN REALLY
GOOD.
HE
THAT BIG, TO BE ABLE T
TOWNS STEPS GAME, TYING
THE FRANCHISE
MAKE IT 32 IN THE QUARTER AND HE
HAS TIED THE FRANCHISE
HAVE A QUARTER TO GO HERE IN
GO.
AND A NEW FRANCHISE RECORD FOR
TOWNS ROOTED AGAIN, TH IS OFF TE
CHARTS.
INCREDIBLE FOR THE FOR
HIM.
FOR THEM, AND THEY DRLY.HACHIMU
JAPANESE HOPE FOR
HIS SAKE ANDND HERE'S A
DRAYMOND SCREEN FOR STEPH AND
THE
>> Kelenna: CURRY. HAMMER IT DO.
HOW HUNGRY OF 12  STILL HAS THE
QUICKNESS.
HE IS G
HACHIMUR HAS.
PLAYING TOGETHER.
THEOSTGIS, AND THE DEFENDERS, C.
MOVE.E-THROW FROMIS PLAY.ICATOC
OF HOW THEY PLAYING WELSH
SHOOTING THE THREE
SQUEEZES IT, SETS UP THEHE LIT
UP IN A HURRY.
>> Michael: MIKE WHAT I HAVE
TIME COMES FROM, WHEW, THE
STRENGTH OF THE
SECOND.
IRVING, CROSS OVER, INSIDE,
LEFT HAND AMBIDEXTROUS,
LOOK AT THIS
SEASON. DRUMMOND.
IRVING
STRIPE.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE
NUMBERS, IT'S THE BROOKLYN.
BUT IT ISN'T JUST CAREER.
NETS LED BY AS MANY AS 30.
THERE IS A FOUL THE C
BROWN.
YOU DON'T WANT TO MISS HOTE.
WIN, BUT YOU ARERE